i want to talk about slide rules this is
a slider rule but to explain what it is
so what we have is a classic old-school
faber-castell
slide rule anyone who is
over 50 or maybe over 60 would have had
to learn to use one of these at school
and actually the use of mathematics for
the previous
300 odd years required the use of this
and you could say that every single
scientific invention or you know through
the age of enlightenment through the
19th century the 20th century would have
relied at some level
on ease of calculation through using the
slide rule and these are only a few out
of the wide variety of problems that can
be worked with the standard slide rule
this is what scientists had so it was
shorthand for being a scientist and it's
so like wonderfully nerdy that i think
the nerds were like yeah this is this is
our this is our sword you know it's a
lightsaber
okay it's actually rather lovely that
the way this moves in and out it's so
beautifully done this instrument it's
actually really pleasurable just going
like this thing with a slide rule it's
not like a calculator it's not digital
you don't get the exact answer you get
an approximate answer but normally
within two to three significant figures
which
should usually be enough for the job
that you're trying to do we have one of
these scales
on the top line here a which is the top
line we have another identical scale
underneath it
on b so there are lots of different
types of scale here but i'm just using a
and b a is this one here and b is
underneath it
let's say we want to multiply
three times four
three times four we look at a and we go
to where three is
and we put
the bottom one at one where three is
then we go up 4
and then we read
where 4 is on the original one and you
can see 4 is at 12 because it's 10 11
12. just say we can do something else
let's say this is something more
complicated 7 7 is a complicated number
let's multiply seven by seven seven
squared so we put the number one at
seven here
one at seven then we go up to seven at
the bottom one
and it exactly comes up at forty 49. so
that's cool what logarithms do and what
this is a physical interpretation of is
that they change multiplication into
addition so we're multiplying two things
but actually we're just adding two
lengths the reason why this is useful
obviously seven times seven we know that
in our heads just say we wanted to
multiply
say two three four five times
six
four
five seven
okay what we do we turn that into two
point three four five times six point
four five seven and let's do the sums so
we'll go to two point three four five
two point
three four five it's probably about
there and we got here six point four
five seven
six point four five seven
and that is
that's almost exactly fifteen
okay
so get rid of our things so three
that would tell me literally within a
few seconds
that
two three four five times six four five
seven is fifteen million and why don't
we just check that four five seven
equals
wow
the real answer fifteen million one four
one
six six five this gives us a handy idea
of what the answer is going to be
multiplication is addition so division
is subtraction so let's say we want to
divide 20
by
three
we go to 20
and we just basically need to take away
three so we put three
where oops where the 20 is there
and go down to one and where is one we
use our hairline here
oh look it's six
between
6.6 and 6.7 this is something which is
kind of quite cool and fun and a bit of
a historical relic but it's not
particularly beautiful thing
unlike
my other
slide rule my prized possession and this
is the holden calculux okay i'm going to
open it it's from 1906
and it comes almost like you know like
like i'm proposing my marriage to you
that i'm getting down on my vended knee
and giving you hold on calculx will you
be my mathematical bride so what this is
is it is a circular slide rule so here
we have the logarithmic scale along a
line
in a circular
slide rule it's in a circle now
let's put that down for a second this
comes with this fantastic sort of set of
instructions the thing is not that many
people collect mathematical instruments
and so you probably get loads of you
know this might have been found by
someone just clearing out their attic
didn't know what it was and i it can't
have been more than a few dozen dollars
so
revised rules tables and formulae for
the holden calculates which is a
circular slide rule now this is just
wonderful absolutely wonderful
price one over six that's a pen is it i
don't i don't know i'm i'm too young
even though i'm old to understand old
english things i'm going to read you a
story
although the ordinary slide rule is
usually acknowledged to be a most useful
and reliable instrument
it has one or two great disadvantages
for instance
it is a most inconvenient article to
carry about in one's pocket
also in the hands of the average user it
is rendered almost useless for any
unusual calculation so
in other words
you would couldn't put this in a pocket
and it's not very elegant
on the other hand
holden calculates it's beautiful it's
like a pocket watch and it's something
that if you ever needed to do fast
approximate analog calculations on the
fly and it was 1906 you could whisk this
out here there are two moving parts
there is
you're moving
this logarithmic scale against the top
one so two sides and you've got there
the hairline
here
you can move
the middle one
and you've got the hairline so again
there are lots of different scales for
doing lots of different things i'm just
going to concentrate on multiplication
and division so just say again
we wanted to say
do
four
times
five
and we can see if you can say close up
we know it's 20 and it's on 20.
this is lovely this thing what do you do
with this what do you do you do
calculations you can do
i sort of take it out and stroke it and
polish it and and put it up there and
you know talk to it quite a lot of times
things are just made for being
functional
and this is something which is not only
is it functional it is a rather
beautiful object and it's you could say
it's a kind of iphone of the um
you know early english 20th century
because this is the height of technology
packaged with beauty
thanks to audible.com for supporting
this video audible has more than 180 000
downloadable titles across all types of
literature including fiction non-fiction
and periodicals i'm an audible user and
particularly enjoy listening to books
when i'm walking the dogs or driving the
car or slogging along on the treadmill
they really make the time pass so much
more quickly now among audible's huge
collection is a book by alex bellos the
person you just watched talking about
slide rules here's alex's adventures in
numberland super easy to find and
download onto your audible app why not
check that one out to find out more
about how to do it go to audible.com
numberphile there you can sign on for a
30-day free trial including your first
book and see what you think
that's 30 days free trial it's a great
service easy to use and our thanks to
audible for supporting the channel